Turquía y Ucrania han confirmado hoy la
renovación del acuerdo por la
exportación de cereal ucraniano que se
llevó a Estambul el julio del año pasado
con la mediación turca y de Naciones
Unidas y que fue firmado entre Rusia y
Ucrania por el que Ucrania fue permitida
que exportase sus productos agrícolas
desde el inicio de la guerra en la
invasión rusa en febrero del año pasado
Rusia quería que este acuerdo fuese
extendido tan solo por 60 días y lo
estaba firmando esta semana que
aseguraban los rusos que sólo estarían
dispuestos a permitir esta prórroga del
acuerdo por 60 días sino por 120 que es
lo que marca el acuerdo moscúno lleva
quejándose de este acuerdo tan solo esta
semana sino que lo ha hecho varios meses
ya porque seguro Rusia que este acuerdo
no le ha permitido aún a que Rusia pueda
exportar sus propios productos agrícolas
y fertilizantes que están bloqueados en
Rusia no porque estén sancionados por
Europa y por los estados y no sino
porque muchas empresas de transporte
internacionales y compañías radoras
temen comercializar con estos productos
rusos por temor de que Estados Unidos y
la Unión Europea les impongan a ellos
mismos sanciones secundarias